je place au questionnaire le
questionnaire dix questions
traditionnelles
le questionnaire le questionnaire votre
juron gros mots ou blasphème favori l'a
fait valoir
pourquoi comme je suis à moitié
américains cefac you aux fins enfin
enfin enfin dans le midi on dit ça on
dit aux fins c'est l'abréviation de fin
de voyage
enfin je n'ai pas plus loin mike capps
son contrat ça veut dire quoi
jamais ça veut dire quelques mots
comment ça veut dire quelque chose pour
vous pas votre juron gros mot blasphème
favori c'est pas ça excusez moi j'en ai
aucun suisse ne jure pas jamais aux
allègements teurs non j'ironise c'est
pire qu'il a dit n'est pas une colère
comme ça non je met pas en colère
tranchade jamais vous aviez des scènes
de ménage avec les actrices vous avez
poussé à mettre des ménages
je ne jure jamais oh non je crois pas
une seconde
or jamais les choses au point il est
bien entendu que je pour majur jeu que
j'ai un juron c'est quand on emploie le
nom de dieu [ __ ] de dieu que dieu me
tripote vain dieu parce que je ne sais
pas comment ça s'écrit cvn gt ou via
yens mon blasphème favoris les versets
sataniques volailles de dieu volailles
de volailles de dieu voilà il de merde
et bord des lacs une charrette à bras pu
te borgne
ça me prenait que et rythme un [ __ ]
mais ça n'existe pas pour les filles
tous les girons sont masculins donc je
dis casse couilles que le cul te pelle
que le cul te pellerey que le cul te
peines de 10 à beaucoup de gens parce
que le cul de beurre et le cul te paie
les regarder dans quelle est alors que
vous verrez lmp ou pas
[Musique]